yeah you know I think you know a
novelist right you know novel great
novelists tend to write the same book
over and over and over again and and
they don't mean to it's not like they
sit down and come up with a theme first
it's just it's what's on their mind it's
what's in their heart and it comes down
their work i think you know journalists
can be the same way if we have the the
self expression of the venue for
expression I mean I you know the
thematics of what I write you know are
repetitive enough so that I noticed and
and I don't I don't intend it that way
but I'm sort of consumed with this
question of what's next and how you
adapt government and how you adapt
political parties and how you drag
people into a future that's only going
to be productive and full of promise
which I think it can be if you envision
it as opposed to if you stumble into it
with all of your institutions becoming
aging and irrelevant so I I do you know
the question I asked over and over again
and I've asked it predominantly of
Democrats the last couple years because
that's what I'm writing my book on but
the question I ask of everyone over and
over again is is what's next what do you
what are you going to change how do you
envision the role of government changing
you know how do you how do we how do we
meet this transition don't tell me as
Republicans do that it can that you know
it's all just going to be Darwinian and
you know that the future belongs to the
to the entrepreneur and everyone else
can just get lost don't tell me as
Democrats do that we're going to go back
to nineteen fifty-five and it's all
going to be fine because it's just a
matter of putting the right priorities
in place and you can stop the future
tell me what we're telling me what the
next iteration of American government is
going to look like I asked that question
over no I'll probably ask you for like
20 more years we'll probably some crank
and I cabin somewhere completely lost my
mind and I'll be right next time other
way